[Music]  I'm going to paradise just for Colton  what are your feelings for Colton now  and what are your feelings on Colton's  motivations because considering he dated  you dated a famous gymnast that went on  Bachelorette me and Colton are just a  big question mark because we haven't  gotten to have that conversation about  where we stand and about how he feels  about me and I don't know how he feels  about Becca and if he's still  heartbroken and so I think a  conversation definitely needs to happen  but like you said you know there have  been tongs that I've wondered okay was  was he interested in me being the  Bachelorette and he wanted to get to  know me first before he was on my season  I tried not to think too much into it  but I'm interested to talk to him and  just see where we stand so you would  want to and if we're both feeling it  yeah we could go on a date just so the  doors open  you